how are you guys doing
hey steve good how are you i'm doing
really good
i want to start with uh when was the
last time a director told you
we really need you to get this in one
take
i've never heard that thank god because
i'm like what
neither have i because that's that's
pressure i mean
i've done something where i've gotten it
in one take but if he had told me
prior to filming that we needed in one
take
that's too much pressure yeah that's a
lot of questions
uh what do you think uh i think people
love learning about like the behind the
scenes of the making of a movie
so what do you think would surprise
people to learn about the making of
tomorrow war
definitely probably uh the training that
we went through
we really went through uh some of the
same training that
you know military people in the military
go through our
uh trainer harry humphreys was actually
in the military and so we
we learned how to move as a team uh how
to shoot guns how to clear a room so you
know if ever something went down we'd be
able to take down some bad guys in a
really tall building um i think that's
that's one thing and
and filming in iceland um
you know we actually went to iceland and
shot on one of the like largest glaciers
i think in europe
and can't there's something that's
really cool that happens on top of the
glacier that we were able to do um
as well i can't give it away but that's
definitely amazing in a time where you
know cgi definitely is taking over like
to actually go and shoot there
yeah yeah yeah the the thing that i
found about this movie is it pulls a bad
boys too
in which that i thought the movie was
over but then there's a whole nother
section to the film uh can you sort of
talk about that that i think people
might not be expecting
this movie i think you know just gives
just gives it another life and it
doesn't
it keeps it from you know being
predictable you know we always want
stuff to be unpredictable so
i think that's really the the greatest
thing about it because you're right
after whatever happens in the movie is
just like
oh is that it you know what i'm saying
so no that definitely it just adds a
whole nother life to it
for sure i i like to think of this as
like the ultimate roller coaster ride
so as soon as you think the roller
coaster is done it just like speeds off
again and
takes you on another journey i'm curious
what did you guys think
when you first saw jk simmons i'm not
sure when you saw him on set if you saw
him on set because
just to me when i saw him i'm like oh he
could just beat all the aliens on his
own
he definitely looked badass it was crazy
i didn't get to i didn't get to work
with him on set
but it was it was cool when i seen it it
was just like yo
jk simmons looks like a badass yeah all
right i'm in a movie with j.k simmons
right
super badass but when i first saw him i
was like oh he seems like a really cool
guy like he was so
open and fun and just hey guys what's up
you know
and then once he turned on his character
i was like oh
that's the og actor right there i just
always think about him in spider-man
completely one of the things about this
film is that it was originally going to
be released by paramount in theaters
and now it's coming out basically fourth
of july weekend on amazon
and i'd argue a lot more people are
going to watch this movie
because it's going to be on amazon can
you sort of talk about that
i love that you argue that argue that i
love that you think otherwise
no no i i i actually don't you know i'm
kind of in question i'm like yeah
it's it's it's you know it's a it's a
great movie you don't want to miss it
but it's like
i've loved that you feel that way
because i that's what we want we want so
many people to watch it and that's
that's the beautiful thing about
streaming
is the access people have yes and i
didn't even it didn't even
i didn't even think about it being out
fourth of july weekend basically so
i didn't even i didn't put two and two
together july 2nd i'm like oh yeah july
4th coming up that's amazing
i love that yeah yeah
but i mean i i know that a lot of people
are home that weekend and this is a this
is a big summer movie
that you can watch for free in your
living room for sure and it's a safe way
to celebrate you know
uh independence day and a good time to
just bring the whole family together
and um hug on your loved ones and and
just have fun
i i am curious for both of you what is
it like fighting
aliens that are basically not there i
mean are you up to like
is it sort of like reliving being an
eight-year-old with your imagination
yeah that's exactly literally that's
exactly right for sure
that's literally not that's yeah
that's exactly right you hit it right on
the head
can you sort of share a little bit
though about filming those scenes and
filming
like just i guess you could talk about
filming some of those scenes
it's i know for like you i know for me
you know i had a reaction moment in it
and it's literally like nothing there
you know what i'm saying you gotta
really like you gotta really
imagine it you it's weird you know it
you put people in situations we watch a
lot of movies we have
we've all been through a lot of feelings
and i think sometimes
no matter what setting you're in a
feeling is a feeling
you know so if i'm shocked terrified
whatever
at you know a clown at a birthday party
i know it's not the same stakes as an
alien coming at you
but you know that feeling and you know
you could turn that feeling up so i look
at it like
yeah it's i it's not there but i mean
that's what our imagination for we've
been training for this our whole life we
didn't even know it for sure
and i i think what was sometimes i
couldn't even
picture the alien in front of me so i
would just picture somebody who's made
me really really mad
that i never got a chance to like you
know express my feelings to and i just
put them there and go ah
you know with a gun or something not
that i want to shoot them at all
is that meisner is that meisner
technique
[Laughter]
one of the things that uh it's really
tough nowadays to make an original story
that isn't based on existing ip and this
is an original story
can you sort of talk about that this is
something that people haven't seen
before it's a
completely original thing that's what
made me fall in love with it
honestly once i heard one side read the
premise i was just like
oh yeah this is this is fire what
drafting people from
the past or the present to the future to
fight a war
that's 30 years in the future of what it
was it's like i mean that's
i was like this is this is it like this
is this is what i
this is the type of stuff i want to be a
part of for sure and it was it was
cool too because it speaks a lot um to
today's times i think with you know how
we have to rely on science to sort of
help um save uh humanity and
also i think what was cool and original
about this film is that
the women were just as badass and in
power as the men were so there wasn't
necessarily some sort of egoic power
struggle that had to happen between the
two sexes
because everybody's on the same page and
we're just here to save humanity so
i thought that was really original too i
also a big fan of larry fong who was
your cinematographer
can you guys talk a little bit about
working with larry and maybe what
surprised you what impressed you
larry's a musician a magician
he is no like not with the camera he's
like an actual
magician he was like doing card tricks
and things
i like watching him on set like he's
sewing his own yeah
like he's like he's like locked in yeah
and i'm just like
i i for me it's just i'm just happy to
be here like this is crazy to just work
with him and
you know hopefully work for him more in
the future i thought just him
in his own was just amazing to me yeah
he's genius though with what he does
he's yeah he yeah he's kind of talented
no as as actors do you pay attention to
like the lenses and stuff they're using
so you know like where the camera is
going to be or how much you sort of just
like i can't think about that
i got to focus on the performance
sometimes for me
sometimes i think i got into it more
there was a film that i shot after this
one and
um i started paying attention to it more
because i mean someday i would love to
be behind the camera so and i think it's
also important as an actor to know how
wide
or tight the shot is so if you know what
lens they're using you
you know you know how much wiggle room
you have in terms of
movement and things like that so yeah on
that note i got to stop i'm just going
to say congrats
hope it's a huge hit i know everyone's
going to watch july 4th
uh thank you so much for your time thank
you so much